you probably know that Hillsdale College
was founded before the Civil War was an
interest in freedom and God and high
learning and good character it's old
it's independent it's widely known do
you know it has a campus in the District
of Columbia Washington DC on Capitol
Hill itself it's called the Allen P
Kirby jr. center for constitutional
studies and citizenship and it might be
an act of haughtiness because we did get
to thinking that we were pretty
successful at teaching the Constitution
United States and all the ideas behind
it two freshmen maybe now we should try
people in the government that'll be
harder it does do that there and it is a
beautiful place I promise if you see it
you will gasp there's an original copy
of the first printing of the Federalist
Papers you can look at first printing of
the Constitution United States after it
was passed by the Convention and sent to
the Congress for the ratification
process there's a lot of education that
goes on there for our students and for
others and if you stop by you'll be very
welcome